now I'm even more excited to tell you
that these shows are made with so much
love in so much care and some of the
best writing that we've ever seen in
television and I'm very very proud of
our show runners and I'm going to bring
them out now and they are Kristen Asst
Tara butters and Michelle physique Asst
better that way hello welcome thank you
thank you
you guys are of course are not strangers
to comic-con no we were the first time
we were here as panelists was on the
pilot of Reaper Reaper fans out there
very cool I was conceived on the
convention floor in 1973 I'm ashamed to
say I was there not in the conceiving
part you know you like to watch uh you
had to go there didn't you uh the the
real challenge of season one was finding
an actor that could personify someone
who existed in comics for a very long
time and who also at the same time
existed as a voice and is now played by
a different actor and I what I can just
tell you is is that when we first sat
down and decided that the person who was
going to be following agent Carter on
her adventures was going to be Jarvis we
we looked hi we looked low and we all
agreed that there was the right person
for it if we could just get him and that
person is James Darcy this is his first
comic-con does not know what to say
he said he said that it was we walked
over and of course they took us through
the back way and the tunnels and stuff
and he turned to me and he said this
doesn't seem very crowded yeah I may
have been wrong I'm very proud to say
that you can't do agent Carter without
agent Carter
it is our extraordinary pleasure every
day to get to work with Haley Atwell
hello
hmm there are two other people who are
very important to this show who could
not make it they're off making a little
movie called Captain America Civil War
and that would be Kevin Feige and lude
Esposito this is the one show that
Marvel television makes with Marvel
Studios Lois is been one of the
champions of this he directed the short
he directed the the pilot and I can
honestly tell you that I don't know that
any of us would be here without Lois
championing it all the way so a big
THANK YOU to Lois and a big shout out to
everybody out in Captain America land so
guys welcome to Comic Con this is a
little different than the last time we
do this when no one really knew who we
were uh and I guess we'll just start out
with with talking to Tara Michelle and
Chris what's it like having a little
eight episodes that suddenly the world
is talking about I remember walking
through I think the Marriott last year
with you and telling Haley you're never
going to be able to do this again just
so you know and it is kind of amazing to
see to kind of walk around with her and
everybody kind of gets all excited and
it's so cool to see all the cosplay that
I've seen of her you have to say the fan
art I are buys everything on it's really
everything if there's fan art you can
put it up for sale live products
probably bought it but I just love that
expression of the fans and how they love
the show and I'm really happy because we
love it so much
and I really wanted people to like it
and I'm glad that they did it's the best
job we've ever had oh yes Emil
so when we started out the hunt for
Jarvis James you had some questions I
think I was going to go with misgivings
but you certainly had to sort of know as
an actor how to play this part can you
talk a little bit about you know when
you first started out when you first got
a call from us and we all said come play
please can play I well I was slightly
worried because in the in the pilot
Jarvis is making a souffle and I can't
actually make a souffle and I was
worried that I would be required to
actually do any of you have made a
souffle when I was it's a complex
process and you've got a time it just
right so my apprehension mainly revolved
around souffle making and I can do a
perfect spotted dick that's an English
pudding but I'm not so good at the
souffles so we had a long conversation
about that and then they explained to me
what acting is and I would not I was
grade though is that is that no one's
ever played an English Butler before so
this was a new thing for you I'm just
reading very new territory here and
actually the thing that the thing that
really sold it to me was when Michaele
and Tareq Chris and Jeff said to me oh
no no but he's going to be with her on
the missions and I said oh great so
there's going to be some fighting and
and they went
yeah Haley's gonna be doing a lot of
fighting and I said and javis will be
behind her doing some fighting and they
went thank you that's how Chris actually
talks just to let you know uh and and
having read the script there was there
was so funny what they had already
written for Jarvis and I've never
actually had an opportunity to do
anything comedic on film before and I
wasn't at all sure that I could do it
but it turns out guys think that I do it
after what thank you for the vote of
confidence it turns out I just had to be
my usual Wally of a self and it would
work out just fine you actually brought
up something that I should also mention
was that you read the first script in
that script was written by two of our
other executive producers that were also
very lucky to have and that's Chris
Marcus and Steve McFeely they also could
not be here because having written
Captain America the First Avenger and
having written Captain America the
Winter Soldier
they have just finished writing and are
on the set at Captain America Civil War
so just have a little bit of a pedigree
here a little bit that we're very proud
of um speaking of very proud of Hayley
Atwell
aside from being the only person I'd let
take my hats uh tell us about Peggy
like you've now played Peggy well you
play Peggy in two features a short and
eight episode suiting out to be 10 more
episodes what is it about that character
that takes you off the big screen and
into our homes I think first of all the
quality of the writing and it was very
clear in the script that you know we'd
seen aspects of Peggy in the First
Avenger but on in this show in
particular there was so many nuances of
character and she was dynamic and
resourceful and fun and sexy and
vulnerable and all these qualities that
that I really enjoy playing and so I am
I jumped at the chance to do it for the
very reason that also I known the Marvel
team for five years and loved them
dearly and she's just kind of kind of
taken over my life in such an amazing
way she's quite fearless and I often
find when I'm having moments of kind of
doubting what I'm doing I think that she
she wouldn't she just goes for it so she
kind of thrust herself into situations
with such kind of kind of wild
abandonment that that I'd love that
opportunity so it's changed my life yeah
true story
we we had the script and and we had
Hailey's interest but it's always a
challenge when you have someone and you
want to make sure that they're coming on
board and she came into the Marvel
offices and and went through our little
quiet security because as you know there
is no Marvel security actually I'm
hoping that no one here is actually
recording anything because you're not
going to leave here alive and we get to
keep your phone and it's bad so don't do
that
anyway uh and so you win in I remember
you went into a little locked room uh
with a script which she then had to give
back as soon as she was done reading and
you had sort of the most amazing
reaction because you went in with like
all these questions that you were
prepared to like gorillas
yeah well do you think you could check
is it and then what happen when you came
out yeah that's how we talk is yes but
um I just well I just loved her and I
want I really hoped that um you know the
writers would get her right when I was
really adamant about about that and I
just read the script the first time and
just came out I think I just whip
amazing I might had nothing to say but
but compliments it was think you know we
were also working with a group of such
talented and skillful writers it's it's
all on the page and it feels like you
just have to turn up and say the lines
and all the works kind of done for you
so I've been very lazy actually okay I
can we can I add to that actually that
you know a show that is set in the 40s
so requires some period dialogue but
also with two of the main characters
being English that's an extraordinary
skill that quite a lot of British
writers wouldn't be able to to pull up
to right period English dialogue and you
guys our writers have just so
beautifully come up with words that I
would never dare to use you know and
they found these fantastic period
dialogue for us and hello like that like
that I am told that we can open the
floor to some QA or is there a Ming
gonna hang oh thank you ah Haley I'm
Haley so I guess I guess I start with
the guy in the Captain America shirt oh
look at that you have like a little
television and everything that's awesome
yeah my name is DJ my questions for
Haley Atwell
do you feel that your characters
decision to pour out Captain America's
blood at the end of the season was right
even though Steve was the only one to
survive or volunteer for operation
rebirth yeah I do think this
the right decision because she'd been
holding on to him the whole season not
really been able to move on she was
grieving him and I think by the end of
the season she'd grown and she it was
her way of getting closure and letting
him go and it was a burial for her in a
way I think also she was just concerned
that if it had gone into the wrong hands
then someone would abuse that power and
I think keeping keeping him alive
through the work that she was doing and
the memory of him served him better but
I think it also makes it more
bittersweet and just makes a better
story and and we shot that on on the
Brooklyn Bridge in New York didn't we oh
yeah yeah you guys want to talk at all
bit that's actually one of our big
partners in the show is ILM and you guys
have heard of ILM it's a little special
effects house Michelle do you want to
talk a little bit about how how helpful
that is and if we built all of this this
is one of the benefits of working with
Marvel is that people want to go into
business with Marvel and so Island has
obviously done a bunch of work for the
Marvel feature side had never done TV
and I think we're a little hesitant
about doing it for a lot less money in a
lot less time but they were such fans of
the material I've actually worked on a
lot of different shows that used visual
effects and it's some of the best work
I've ever seen you actually went up and
visited them yes it was amazing to get a
tour of ILM and see movies and stuff
that you've seen you growing up and see
the assets there but the amazing thing
for us was when you're having to build a
city they have 30 years worth of assets
they were able to call on in their
library and rejigger for us to help make
New York City come to life which was a
big part of our show we have another
question hi this question is for Haley
I wanted to know what your favorite line
from the show was that you feel like
some depth of themes of the show because
uh I know my value line was pretty
awesome well it's I mean ever it must be
I mean everyone knows the line that
defined Peggy and it's you know
something that has kind of touched
locked people that I've met conventions
over the world in the last few months
but it's I know my value anyone else's
opinion doesn't really matter and that's
I think for me something that she she
discovers over time and that she doesn't
need praise from anyone because she she
has determination and purpose and she's
kind of living out her destiny and with
the support of the right people around
her and and I it's been amazing going to
these conventions and meeting especially
young people young boys and girls coming
up to me going I know my value to and
think just melts my heart it's so
humbling and I think that's kind of that
what that's what gives Peggy in the
first season real depth she has she's a
very independent spirit but then at the
same time you're there's a wonderful
scene that I love where Jarvis is
talking to her and saying you can't run
away from people they're trying to help
you and you realized in that moment that
he sees her vulnerability and that in in
putting up this wall from having lost
Steve she's scared of letting other
people in and Jarvis is the person kind
of like a kind of kindred spirit who's
gently tapping on the shoulder to tell
her that she's not alone so I think he
has some pretty fabulous lines to
I just I I'd be remiss there is in the
show there is a Captain America radio
show and and there's there's somebody on
this panel who does one of the voices I
take us back to the 1940s would you
welcome to the Captain America adventure
that's mortifying uh now guys we're
season two something new we're where we
off to we are off to Hollywood so so
it's we're in the 1940s we're still in
the same time and we're moving everybody
sort of lock stock and barrel off to
sunny California in in a sense it's it's
1947 so we're saying it's about six
months after the show ended and things
are different
we'll start and will and will you know
we'll see people are in different
positions and people are actually not
everyone is in New York anymore um and
there's some history that we're not
quite sure and some people aren't
talking to each other anymore and then
Peggy will get called to Los Angeles to
help investigate a murder
47 Los Angeles was the same year as the
Black Dahlia Murder so we really love
the idea of the sort of glamour of old
Hollywood and the sort of classic sort
of film noir grit and crime of Los
Angeles so we're kind of really having
fun and it rude but the story that is
just changing location generates such
great stories and great interactions
between the care
there's Anna right now are we leaving
dear Jarvis home does he get to come
along Jarvis is actually already there
he's been there helping Howard start set
up his new estate in Beverly Hills he's
doing some contract work for the
government and just as a hobby decided
to open a movie studio can I can I ask a
question yeah I might not be able answer
am I gonna get to meet my wife
finally
does he get to cost it he might get to
I'm not sure you guys get to look at we
got stuff here who what do we got and
another question for a song hi my name
is chella my name is Zoe my name is
adria and I'm Julie and we have a
question about season two so we're
wondering if we'll see any historical
people or places and what will we see
about Peggy's life after Captain America
in terms of relationships
well Abraham Lincoln won't be in the
show this aren't places I would say you
know we're hopefully I mean we're
talking about sort of really iconic Los
Angeles places that haven't really
changed much since the 40s um so if we
can we can do it we'll shoot their
famous people uh really I tended to
movie stars and yeah in countries and
that's article no plans for actual
historic figures but until just now and
then will we see I would say that Peggy
has has put Steve sort of memory to rest
and has a couple of new opportunities oh
she's a [ __ ] No
and I think on that because we have a we
have still more show for you
I very much like to thank Chris Taha
Michelle
you